That's it
It's as simple as that.
You just witnessed two types of attack that are common occurance in large cities.
But here, the attackers were not lucky.
Their targets were Aikido practicioners,
a very efficient defense system.
The term Aikido is probably new to most people.
Aikido is not a sport, it is a martial art from Japan
The meaning of "Ai" is the union, "Ki" is the spirit, and "Do" is the path
Here, physical strenght is secundary
Aikido is the way to tune one's spirit with that of others, and by extension, with the universe.
Mr Clement, the representative of Aikido at the French Judo Federation tells us whether Aikido got implanted easily in France.
No. Aikido was first imported by Master Mochizuki [Minoru], who was a student of Master Ueshiba but who had modified the techniques.
Aikido really started with Master Tadashi Abe who taught the actual techniques that he had learned from Master Ueshiba.
When he returned to Japan, my friend Nocquet took over the leadership of the Aikido section at the Judo Federation.
Andre Nocquet, 50 years-old, propagator of Aikido in Europe, what is your exact title?
I'm an Aikido Master.
How did you become an Aikido Master?
I became an Aikido Master by travelling to Japan.
Before that you were a Judo instructor?
I was a Judo teacher
What did you do in Japan?
I practiced at the world Aikido headquarters under the founder, Master Ueshiba.
He is an extraordinary 86 years-old man with a face of a striking purity.
He still lives in Tokyo in the dojo where he teaches this extraordinary discipline.
Great Master, what is Aikido?
The spirit of Aikido is to foster love, it is the path of peace, the realisation of love.
There is good and bad love. Aikido conserves the good and we try to teach people to walk the right path.
Aikido has nothing to do with either Judo or religion.
Aikido is all inclusive and the goal is love.
How long did you stay in Japan?
I stayed almost three years in his home.
Learning Aikido.
Yes, learning Aikido under his direct guidance.
When you arrived in Tokyo, did you konw anything about Aikido?
I had studied it in France before under Master Tadashi Abe who had been sent to develop this discipline.
I got up every morning at 5 a.m. and cleaned the room with other Japanese disciples.
You have to clean the room.
You must clean before learning.
If you tried to ask people in France to clean the room before practice, it would not be possible.
What differenciates Judo from Aikido?
Judo is a sport with prearranged forms.
Just like boxing or Greco-Roman wrestling where you have to observe a ritual.
Aikido is a very efficient defense system in the street, it works at mid-distance.
Can anybody do Aikido?
Anybody can practice Aikido, it is an excellent method for physical education and body coordination.
For children too?
Yes, it is a remarquable gymnastic for young people.
Do you think that Aikido brings something to mankind?
Yes, it brings a lot in terms of self control. During an attack, the reflex action comes into play, not the brain.
It is the concept of Zen buddhism that tells us to make the void and to let the instinct act.
Why is Aikido less well known in Europe than Judo, Jujutsu or Karate?
It is normal, Aikido was a secret art 20 or 25 years ago but Master Ueshiba, the founder decided to open it up.
Why was it secret?
It was reserved to hgih rank people, the imperial police.
Can Aikido be deadly?
Of course, just like words, we can say both good and bad things, it is the same thing.
More than 200 000 Japanese people practice Aikido
There are 30 000 practicioners in the united States where this art grows steadily, as well as in Europe with 18 000 enthusiasts.
by itself, France counts 4000 of them, from all classes of society.
Listen to a taxi driver, and then a woman, explain to you whay they practice Aikido.
How long have you been doing Aikido?
For two years.
Why do you practice Aikido?
In my job, I am stuck in the car for many hours and although it is not physically tiring, I am very stressed because of traffic.
I feel that Aikido relaxes me, gives me good reflexes that I can use in traffic, and it could be a useful defense if I ever got attacked.
I practice Aikido because it is a very good physical exercise.
I have been doing it for 3 years and i have an interest for oriental philosophies so I like to study the like between Aikido and Zen.
I'm an office worker and i have been practicing for 12 years, I am 3rd Dan.
I practice because it is an intelligent physical exercise that complements well my sedentary lifestyle and that satisfies both my body and my spirit.
I have been doing it for a year and it is good for me because it doesn't require strenght.
I'm a photographer and i live in the suburbs so I soemtimes come home late at night so Aikido provides me with an efficient means of defense is needed.
Japan has several military arts
Some use weapons like Kendo, the Japanese fencing, or Kyudo, the archery.
Others like judo or Karate do not use them and Aikido could be put in that category if it did not use the same principles for empty-handed techniques and weapons practice.
During his youth, Master Ueshiba studied all of the martial arts and he never ceased daily the intense daily practice of these many techniques,
which allowed him to create Aikido, the synthesis of all known Asian self-defense systems based of his tireless study.
To the profane, Aikido techniques seem extraodrinarily fast and precise but the numerous applications only become efficient after several years of training.
Beginners have to learn to move around their adversary at angles from 180 to 360 degrees without loosing their balance.
On a physical aspect, Aikido movements can be compared to that of a pendulum
and the attacker will find himself directed into a circular motion, until  he loses the control of his agrssive gestures,
which prevents him to make use of his flexor or extensor muscles, the only means of action of a human being.
Aikido's fundamental principles do not aim at break of strain joints, but to bend them in their natural axis of action until their limit.
This localized pain leads to a loss of balance.
The art of falling is different to that of Judo and the Aikido practicioner immediately gets up after the projection by graciously rolling over the wrist, the elbow, or the shoulder.
This provides an escape route from a painful lock,
to avoir injury due to the contact of the ground on a vital point,
to recover one's balance, and to get up in order to face the adversary again.
Because of its soft style, Aikido is the most approppriate personnal defense for women and older men.
Thos who choose this discipline can practice over a whole lifetime and keep improving, regardless of the age.
Abotu the typical Japanese uniform, the top is similar to that of Judo
and the black trousers are used to hide the all important footwork from the adversary.
To conclude this demonstration presented by Andre Nocquet and his student, Jean-Daniel Cauhepe,
demonstration that speaks for itself in terms of their efficacy whatever the number of attackers.
Let's give the final word to Master Ueshiba, the founder of this martial art where the spirit always wins over brutal stenght.
Master ueshiba says:
"I created Aikido so that all bodies and spirits are healthy. I did so so that the entire world can be one and i rejoice of it."
May he be heard in our tormented world.